time for action climate scientists warn
big changes have to be made to limit
global warming but will politicians
listen and what's the fallout if they
don't this is inside story
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome to the program i'm rob matheson
now for more than a century
industrialization has spread across much
of the world and we've been squeezing
the life out of our natural resources
the planet is getting warmer than the
places on it where humanity can live
healthfully are getting fewer the un's
intergovernmental panel on climate
change commonly known as the ipcc has
brought together scientists from 195
countries to solve the problem in the
last eight months it's published two
reports looking at the causes and the
effects of climate change its third one
has just been released suggesting what
we can do to reverse the damage
it says limiting global warming to a
target of 1.5 degrees celsius is beyond
reach unless big changes are made they
say fossil fuels have to be reduced and
alternatives have to be developed cities
have to be smaller and more walkable
industry has to change production
methods planting more trees and
developing low emission agriculture
systems would help to pool carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere but
switching to many of these systems can
be costly governments will be tough to
persuade even though the world has the
cash to pay for the changes
wealthy countries are largely
responsible for much of the damage
caused by climate change but it's often
developing nations that are affected the
most the food charity oxfam says there's
a risk of unthinkable famine in east
africa it says up to 28 million people
in that region will face extreme hunger
if the rains don't come again this year
21 million people are already going
hungry because of conflict flooding and
a widespread two-year drought and more
than 13 million across somalia kenya and
ethiopia have been forced to leave their
homes looking for water and farmland
okay let's bring in our guests in
guildford in the uk we've got andy
reisinger he's a member of the bureau of
the intergovernmental panel on climate
change he's also vice chair of working
group three he was partly responsible
for producing the substance of this
report in dhaka in bangladesh we have
swan hassan she's chief executive of the
bangladesh environmental lawyers
association and she's also a goldman
environmental prize winner and in
brussels stefan zinger is joining us a
senior climate science and global energy
policy advisor on the climate action
network international very good
afternoon to you thank you very much
indeed for joining us andy let me start
with you given the fact that you were
partly responsible for the production
and the content of this report we have
had similar reports in the past what is
significant about this one
probably two things one is it is clear
that we're not on track to limit warming
to 1.5 degrees and time is running out
if we want to keep that goal within
reach
but there's also now clear evidence of
of really positive progress which hasn't
been enough to turn the curve yet but
but we've for so for example there's
been massive falls in the cost of of
some key renewable energy resources
which means they're now cost competitive
with fossil fuels in many areas
we've seen a spread of climate policies
more than half of global greenhouse gas
emissions are at least in principle
covered by climate laws and these are
vital tools that we can use to
accelerate action to the extent needed
that we actually want to limit warming
to 1.5 degrees
the headline from the at least from the
the short analysis that i have of it
here says we can halve emissions by
2030. that is a very confident statement
given what we have been hearing over the
last few years is this dependent on a
whole variety of different elements
coming together in order to make this
work
the options differ across the different
sectors but yes in aggregate um at costs
of up to about 100 us dollars per tonne
of co2 equivalent avoided we could
reduce global emissions to about half of
the current levels within the next 10
years but but the way you achieve it in
different sectors look very different so
in the energy sector it's largely
transitioning from the use of fossil
fuels towards renewable energy or
increased
use of alternative local carbon fuels
whereas in transport um
it's it's much more about
electrification
or in agriculture it's about protecting
natural ecosystems and
increasing the efficiency of
agricultural production systems so we
need less land to feed um the global
demand for nutrition
so so the the entry points differ from
sector to sector but collectively we
have a wide range of tools available
stefan zinger i i know you've just had a
very short time to have a look at the
the headlines of the report but is there
anything in the report which
with all credit to andy and his team
that we couldn't have guessed already
well um
i think we need to we need to put this
in a political context here although the
ipcc is not policy prescriptive it's
supposed to be policy relevant
in the end it will be policy
prescriptive whether we like it or not
because it shows very clearly and we
congratulate the ipcc for that one that
they show that um
technologies like solar and wind
like halting deforestation and tropical
forests like changing our diets to
what's less meat-based food
and energy efficiency will exactly do
that what andy has said
help us to give us the opportunity to
reduce our emissions
by about half
in 2030 in this decade which is
necessary
to have a survival target
of 1.5 see global warming
which in itself will not be a paradise
which also will require lots of
adaptation but this was not the issue
here
um but that is a minimum i think what we
need to have a livable planet to protect
ecosystems to protect vulnerable
communities
um and to protect poor people
um from the catastrophic impacts from
climate change from sea level rise from
storms and horizons so in that context
that report has provided some new things
um and that's very very important for
policymakers for the business
and the
finance industry
second thing i think it's very important
to to realize
that the report
has said that we need to scale up
financing
in all countries for all sectors by
factor six roughly
um to have the chance to meeting the
challenge that requires significant
mobilization
of finances of money but also a policy
of legislation and changes in
legislation and countries to make sure
that only
resilient climate resilient
and clean energy technologies and clean
um
technologies which help the poor
which help the forests are being
promoted
um end up being encouraged i think
that's very very important and that
brought the report out i also have to
say last point here that for us as
climate action network international
representing thousand five hundred
ngos worldwide the the report is not
perfect we have many things in there we
do not like there are many things we are
falling through the grit
but that's a way if you have a
governmentally
negotiated text which is not purely
based on the ursus that's the way it is
and we know that that has happened in
the past but overall
it's still a very valid wake-up call to
the policymakers the powerful
and the impactful of this world to
change course throughout the world to
avoid disastrous climate change
syed
all of this i'm sure is are statements
that um given your position in the
bangladeshi and environmental lawyers
association you would agree with but
it's all very well saying to countries
you must change your industries you must
change your agriculture and so on if you
come to a country like bangladesh where
its economy is can be tumultuous at
times where it can be under strain
when it comes to for example the
suggestion that everybody should wean
themselves off fossil fuels that's not
something that bangladesh
can be willing to do
very easily simply because of the
structure
i
don't think bangladesh should be
reluctant
in moving towards a hundred percent
renewable energy policy if a country
like rwanda can commit itself to a
hundred percent renewable party why
can't bangladesh do it and also
bangladesh as a member of the most
vulnerable
countries forum it in fact committed
that by 2050 it will move to hundred
percent renewables and as the first
speaker just said that it has already
been proven that renewable can be much
less expensive than the fossil fuel and
bangladesh has the
worst air in the world our global report
has just come out that our air is one of
is the worst in the world
so bangladesh uh also has authority on
renewable energy it should be smart
enough it should have the vision to
really work on the commitment that it is
it has made in the international
community but for a country like
bangladesh it's important also for us to
remember
that most of the fossil fuel projects
that we are doing in our part of the
world are being funded by by the
developed world so the funding for
fossil fuel must stop immediately across
the world
once they are pushed to that situation
then only the political government will
think about switching to renewable
otherwise renewable otherwise the fossil
fuel is not only attractive because it's
being funded by the foreign
countries there is huge deal of
corruption in most of the fossil fuel
projects that
are being sponsored throughout the world
so bangladesh government would also
always argue about not having enough
land but there are models that are being
shown that are being practiced elsewhere
where you can actually have your
cultivation in one patch of life at the
same time you can have solar panels and
the western world must come forward and
support us with technologies where we
can have renewable projects with less
language
have you seen any indication over the
last few years as this problem has
become more more obvious
that there is a change in attitude of
those funding these projects is there a
change within bangladesh i don't want to
single out bangladesh but just as an
example is there an indication that
bangladesh is
changing its way and actually doing
something practical about this if the
funding model changes as well
with the change in the funding model the
government of bangladesh has already
abundant 10 of its planned coal-based
power plants
we are uh
trying to you know impress upon other
governments like the japanese government
so that it withdraws from uh the
coal-based power plants is planning to
support in bangladesh we have seen some
success that one uh
phase of the rampal gold-based power
plant which is just beside a world
heritage site has been abundant because
the government could not manage funds
yes there are governments who are saying
that they will not be funding new fossil
fuel uh plans here in bangladesh but for
the part of the bangladesh government
it's switching from coal to lng it's not
making smart commitment practical
commitment it's not drawing up action
plan to deliver against its own
commitment made in the international
forum to go hundred percent renewable
it's also not doing enough to deliver
against its own commitment to both 10
renewable which was set for 2020 now
it's saying it's rising its uh
target the edgy agency that we have has
already said that we can switch to 40
percent renewable by just converting all
the rooftops into solar panels but the
government is just not working with the
right set of mind
andy i had a very brief look at uh at
the report itself and it is an extremely
long and very very detailed report but
if i please correct me if i'm wrong on
this but section b two of the report
seemed to suggest that reductions in
greenhouse gas er fuels from fossil
fuels and industrial processes had been
less than emissions increases from
rising global activity levels in
industry energy supply transport and
agriculture and buildings now i took
that to mean that basically whatever
savings we're making in trying to reduce
the amount of co2 there is in the
atmosphere is actually being outstripped
by the level of industrialization and
expansion in terms of construction and
agriculture and so on um how do you
redress that balance
but by going harder on i mean what we've
seen in the past is a slight reduction
in the amount of carbon dioxide
emissions per unit of energy that we're
consuming
we can reduce that much faster by by far
more rapidly switching towards renewable
energy systems for example so that would
simply reduce the amount of carbon
dioxide that we release
into the atmosphere for every unit of
energy we consume
if at the same time we manage to
increase energy efficiency which most
countries are doing over time already
anyway but if we can accelerate that
further we can achieve much faster
reductions but over the last 10 years
those small gains we've had from energy
efficiency and a slight reduction in
what's called the carbon intensity of
energy supply so that's the amount of
carbon we emit for kilowatt of of energy
energy we produce um
that simply has been outstripped by the
by the increasing global come from both
consumption and just increased activity
in economies around the world
but
there's multiple levels that we can
apply
and one of the issues i think is that
for many governments there's a there's
historically been a single entry point
to climate policy let's focus on
just
just the the the power supply let's
focus just on on agriculture let's focus
on pricing but not on other things and
one thing the report tries to bring out
is that a coordination of policies both
of climate policies with each other but
also
the greater synergies between broader
development policies can open up the
option space
and
examples are if you reduce fossil fuel
use then you typically in bangladesh for
example would get large core benefits
for human health with benefits with the
with the with those benefits actually
measurable in monetary terms to the
extent that they would actually make it
worthwhile but it's a question of
coordination between health departments
and energy departments to actually allow
governments to realize those benefits
and then move more confidently in that
direction so that is exactly where we're
shifting development into a space that
allows a greater flexibility to apply
climate policy can be really important
and that's one of the key themes that
comes out of our report
stefan it seems a lot of this from what
andy is saying centers around
a tremendous amount of goodwill and a
tremendous amount of coordination
between you know governments around the
world and individual departments as andy
was saying health departments around the
world um
which in the past has not exactly been
the the template i mean we saw to some
degree the the level of fractured
connection there is between different
countries when uh when covert broke is
there is there any way of actually
fixing that and fixing it quickly
because if i understand what andy's
saying correctly that level of
communication that level of
interactivity is absolutely key to all
of this
that's right
and as you mentioned the covet pandemic
unfortunately we have seen there was a
there was an um
i should say it apartheid
the um the rich countries the wealthy
countries which have the money
to develop the wac signs um have stored
capped the wax signs for themselves
and give only a little bit to developing
countries that was not a good example
and i think we need to learn from that
and i think we all and
i'm coming from a rich country from
belgium being a german
we need to embed in policy making
independent of climate change
right for all issues regarding
sustainable development we also have the
sdgs
the sustainable development goals which
are also very important
to bring in the idea and to fight really
for the idea for global solidarity
for for um overcoming inequality between
nations but also within nations
and um i think that's where
so
forgive me forgive me steph and i wanted
to come on to cydda because of the point
there that came out in the report which
was the future planning of cities which
cities had to be to be and i'm
summarizing here but essentially they
had to be smaller more easily walkable
and of course that makes perfect sense
unless you're talking about a city like
dhaka for example or many of the other
cities that we could we could name that
have high pollution rates and so on
seida what do you think would be a way
of adapting a city like yours to be able
to integrate at least some elements
that are contained with this within this
report so that um
places like daca places like new delhi
for example don't for once of a better
phrase offset the benefits of any
newer other cities that have been
planned in different ways around the
world
see
first thing is we all want to be like
las vegas
and then we forget our own culture we
forget our own way of lifestyle so the
development paradigm has to shift we
must not be following the
extremely exploitative and
irresponsible lifestyle of the western
countries that is what has led to this
problem of climate change
i think it's very important that
you see the problem of urbanization is
irreversible one once you develop an
urban area you just destroy the entire
thing once and for all you can't just
go back and you know go back to the
natural state of the area
for a for a city like dhaka it is
important to
understand that we don't want to be
singapore we want to be
dhaka and for a city like delhi that is
also something that they have to realize
second is transportation dhaka everyone
here most of the middle class upper
middle class rich people we all have a
car because that is the symbol of status
and that is what the western lifestyle
has taught us to have but it has at end
of the day become a
completely car locked city cars just
don't move so we have to switch to smart
public transportation that will ease the
burden on burning of fossil fuel it will
also ease the pressure on the city roads
and all of us in dhaka if you have to do
our offices in person we lose three to
four hours every day on the road
so it has to be a comprehensive planning
there is no greenery in dhaka all the
urban forestry is gone we had beautiful
lawns in front of our houses now all our
forest all our lawns all our gardening
has
uh switched to our rooftop
forgive me i'm going to interrupt you
there because if what you're saying is
prompting a response from our two other
guests um stefan let me go to you first
then i want to come to andy for his
response steph on you right at the start
you had a point to make there
yeah i can fully fully support was my
colleague from from bangladesh that
public transport is one but not the only
um key fundamental for making cities
more livable
um that's one point but i would like to
go a little bit broader as i said before
and i started on equality
um i think we would need to understand
where do we need to reduce emissions
primarily i'm not saying
i'm saying everyone needs to do a spit
right um
but i think we need to understand that
rich countries
rich populations in particular and the
ipcc has also told us that about um 10
of the populations worldwide and also
the rich people are responsible for
about almost half of the global
emissions and that's an issue we need to
address in all countries the rich people
have to pay for that one
and they have to make sure
and we have to make sure that this is
being addressed because it's an issue of
of national inequality but also
international inequality is very
important poor countries
are not the sources of the pollution we
have been facing and they will not be
the sources of pollution we are facing
of course they have to contribute
as appropriate to what we want but if
you cannot compare
um a per capita emission citizen of the
us with someone who's left who lives in
bangladesh andy i want someone who lives
in peppa
stephanie but let me
let me finish that one please
let me finish it one please and i think
that's where equity comes in where we as
the north
have the fundamental
duty moral duty principal duty because
it's also in our interests to help
developing countries
to adapt to climate change and to
mitigate climate change to give them and
to help them with resources with
technologies with investments
right it's not only
it's not only in in
in our own countries we need to help
them as well because we also have
contributed to the mass in the past if
you look at historical emissions which
are very well displayed in the spm
in in figure 2 i'm talking about not
technology here not technology i'm
talking about this details here um but
you look at the spm and you see this
the the the historic emissions of the
rich countries
are stephanie forgive me i am going to
interrupt you because unfortunately time
is kind of coming up against us but andy
let me come back to you because you had
a point to make we have maybe a minute
or so left on the on the show if i can
ask you to be reasonably brief
i just wanted to pick up on a point that
syeda made about
city infrastructure is a really good
example one key innovation in the ipcc
report is that we take a dedicated look
at ways of shifting behaviors and how to
meet service demands without increasing
emissions and so
providing infrastructure that enables
people to take their own behavioral
choices i used to live in delhi i used
to ride a bicycle there and you take
your life in your own hands making sure
that that city growth
provides the choices for people to lead
more sustainable lifestyles that's
that's greenery that's urban gardens
that that's that's public transport
that's individual no car transport these
are design choices that are being made
every day as cities continue to grow
it's not a once-off thing
because unfortunately time is against us
andy ricino thank you very much indeed i
want to thank all our guests andy
reisinger
and stefan singer thank you too for
watching you can see the program again
anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle is at aj inside
story from me rob matheson and the
entire team here in doha goodbye for now
[Music]
you